welcome to our divx talks this month we
are talking about the past month about
the economies in the United States in
Germany in Asia with me in the studio is
haiku Peters of DB research what does
how did the world economy perform and
what does the data tell us the divx felt
slightly and maya and is on a positive
level at the moment and at this level it
points to a growth rate of work on we
have slightly above three percent okay
the day bigs i forgot to mention that is
the indicator of the Deutsche Bank
what's measuring the world economy and
you and you said that it's that it's
slowing what are the reasons behind that
especially the sentiment indicators and
the United States disappointed and it's
now at the level of below I'm 50 and so
it's it's points to contract contract
construction of the of the manufacturing
sector if you look at the other regions
and the modern monetary union european
monetary union the indicators increased
also an adria both for japan and for
china on China the levels slightly above
50 so an expansion on the range modest
the Chinese economy let's talk about the
eurozone so the signs are not really
clear some things are improving some are
nuts what is improving maybe to start
with that what we saw in the last month
was that the sentiment indicators were
up and all our countries of the monetary
union but they're still on the level
below 50 for each of the country so for
the second quarter M it points to a
further construction of the economy and
this would be this seven decline of gdp
and the monetary union so we are still
on there in the recession in the
monetary union but they're also signs of
light at the end of the tunnel so maybe
you can mention those what we expect and
the course of the year we expect to
recover a recovery and that is starting
the second half in the third quarter and
the fourth quarter we expecting slightly
positive growth rates again we expect
that the sentiment indicators and
continue to
to improve in the next month and also we
we expect that we have a positive and
credit impulse and also that the
negative effect of the austerity
measures is slowing at the moment so we
have a less less impact on the less
negative impact of the austerity
measures mm-hmm we'll talk deeper about
the euro crisis lighter in our talk
focused on Germany and Europe what the
people can see on the W dots de / made
in Germany and beside that we'll be
talking about for example the Federal
Reserve how it will act maybe in the
next month concerning the US economy so
stay tuned thank you so much hi capitis